so you got to keep the toppings full
okay got it
I'm on top of that you don't fit in just
that yeah hey something that might be
your picture on the wall
Oh Employee of the Year when does she
work what I was just wondering when she
works
butas me Oh Congrats out of the other
side is you get all the free Froyo you
know mm-hmm you can't believe how
delicious too dear and also fat free
thank God because my boyfriend he just
got back from his tour in Afghanistan
he's coming here to pick me up he should
be here in a minute I haven't seen him
in a year a whole year you say hey
Russell I'm good now if you need extra
shirt or anything they're gonna be in
there because these seem to shrink
uh-huh okay you a girl can't get enough
of that stuff I mean you should have
some it's free no I'm okay I'm I'll have
some later
I just got back from Afghanistan I'm
here looking for my girlfriend Latia no
it's not what it's me
apparently she doesn't work anymore
Thanks
[Music]